you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the former government minister anna
subree and the article columnist ali
muraj
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now well the times
says the outcome of the french
presidential election hangs in the
balance
after the incumbent emmanuel macron won
the first round of the vote
the ft front page pictures president
macron face to face with far-right
candidate marine le pen who came second
in the vote and will face him in the
second round of the election
the guardian also leads on the battle
for the french presidency with the
headline macron and le pen face off in
fight for france's future
the telegraph features the news that
chancellor rishi sunak has referred
himself to the minister's interest
watchdog after his wife's non-dom status
and the u.s residency card he held while
in his job came to light
the mirror leads with comments by the
queen who says her bout of coronavirus
left her tired and exhausted
the metro also has those details of the
queen's experience with covid
and the sun gives its front page to a
story about brooklyn beckham and his new
wife's new jaguar
and reminded that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and we're joined tonight by anna subri
and ali mirage welcome to you both hope
you're both well let's start with the
french election and have a look at the
financial times uh front page and they
they have that photo with uh both
candidates facing each other as they
will be doing on the 24th of april in
the second round of elections anna
yes
so quite rightly this is dominating most
of the front pages and i don't think
there's any surprise that it is going to
be a runoff between macron and le pen
and there seems to be some debate as to
whether or not macron actually has done
better than he had done in 2017 or not
but the margin is about 28 24
between the two of them
and so most of the other candidates or a
number of the other candidates have
backed well not so much back to macron
but said
just don't vote for le pen though others
have come out of him and he's not gonna
have in the next two weeks a hell of a
fight to see off le pen
um before that final
election in um it's on april 24th
so
it's it's going to be ish it's going to
be tough for i think and for macron
certainly last time because of course
he's an incumbent
uh i'm hoping of course that he makes it
through
yes and ali many saying that that it
probably will be a lot finer than uh one
might have thought the the gap between
uh macron and le pen come april the 24th
well i think le pen is going to pick up
the votes of eric zamore uh who's even
further to the right than she is and
actually has made her seem to be a more
centrist figure
and she's also rebranded her party uh in
recent years uh from the national front
to the national rally has been seen uh
with pictures of her cats and
and gardening etc she's trying to soften
her image and detoxify her party's brand
but it was very interesting this evening
with macron addressing his supporters
mentioning the enlightenment and that
will not only be um a great relief to
the 18th century uh german philosopher
immanuel kant but also really outlines
the choice that french voters are going
to have in this election between
liberalism globalization uh an outward
looking france which is going to play
its key role in the eu in a world where
macro wants to be the key leader post
um angela merkel and an illiberal vision
which is being outlined by
uh his opponent mary le pen who is much
more deglobalization
kovid would have helped that but is also
polling pretty well in rural areas so
this is as much about economics as it is
about
emotions and identity and macron
sorry and le pen has really fed into
that very very well so i think that's
how this election is going to be framed
and that's the choice in two weeks time
yes and anna she has moved away from the
the anti-immigration stance of of the
party and as ali said softened her image
and chosen to focus on the cost of cost
of living
yes um
i i think i would say of course that
she's pretended to move away from
immigration and i think it's interesting
and of course i'm heartened to see
macron standing there with the eu flag
and of course she's in eu deeply uh eu
cynical and so in many ways terry
mentioned the brexit word but
that element will come into this
election and i i'm i'm so pleased to see
macron making the positive case uh as
ali has described but also making very
much the positive case for the european
union i think also of course there's the
putin factor and what's happening in
ukraine because of course she's also an
apologist many say
um for putin so i think the cards are
with macron and as i say iob wins i
think it's important very important for
europe
um and obviously for france
yes he said to his uh in his speech
tonight to his uh on march supporters
and that rally in paris that you should
overcome your differences um in a
political action of unity for our
country he saluted all candidates in in
the first round and by name but he
didn't
include marine le pen interestingly
ellie
well it is interesting and what is also
interesting uh jillian is the fact that
the old gaulist and socialist parties
have completely been hollowed out and
marginalized i mean back in 88 they had
about 54 percent of the vote tonight
they've got six percent between them
it's absolutely incredible and if you go
back to 2016 where
uh macron then only 39 launched his uh
republic on marsh party which was really
designed to move beyond the old
socialist
and and conservative offering and come
up with something completely new it was
it was really brave of him and he's
actually done pretty well he's still
sitting pretty well although he did have
those protests a few years back when uh
petrol prices were increased with the g
lejeune but i do think look macron is a
product of globalization he is the
archetypal
french uh metropolitan a high priest he
went to the ecco national de
administration the finishing school for
french elite bureaucrats an ex-banker
he's playing well he's cut taxes he
appeals to certainly the middle classes
and the wealthier classes of france but
le pen is really positioning herself
very much on the cost of living issues
she's also
trying to target those people in the
periphery as even macron wrote in 2016
in his own pamphlet that if you neglect
the periphery the rural voters you do so
at your peril well that's what le pen's
targeting and we're going to have to see
if she's successful i still think she's
got a mountain to climb but certainly
she's uh come a long way and eric zamora
further to the right makes her look more
moderate actually looking at the
guardian their headline macron and pen
face off in fight for for france's
future anna do you think that she is
within uh touching distance we have to
take into consideration the votes the
second time around on the 24th of april
of all those that that voted for the
entire twelve candidates and we had
jean-luc milan saying tonight uh
appealing to his voters not to vote for
marine le pen but our reporters out in
paris had spoken to several of his
supporters who said second time round
they would vote for le pen
yeah look i i don't think you should
ever it's always very dangerous isn't to
say oh macron we'll do it and it is a
lot closer it feels a lot closer than
perhaps many
are saying i think the other thing which
is really interesting and ali obviously
analyzes it beautifully but you know it
is extraordinary that in france the
choices between what basically a social
democratic blair right sort of yeah
that's where he is radical centrist
politician
and somebody from the far right because
marine le pen absolutely is from there
however much she might want to hug her
cats and all the rest of it that is her
background it's all about branding in
order to win votes didn't get her heart
she's changed at all that is the choice
facing france in 2022 i think that is a
very concerning thing and it speaks
volumes about the state of politics
actually in so many democracies we saw
it in america with trump we saw it in
our own country with brexit we see it
again now in france quite extraordinary
let's move to the um
telegraph front page and and to domestic
politics and rishi sunak who's not had a
a brilliant
week that's an understatement really
there statement yes
um sunak faces inquiry into his
financial interest but this is by his
own request ali
that's right he wants to refer himself
to uh the independent adviser on the
ministerial code lord geit who if you uh
recall uh looked at boris johnson's text
messages uh to various donors and was
sort of kept in the dark by his own sort
of admission on that so he wants to
refer himself to
to lord guy and yes wish you so next had
a tough few weeks he's had a tough few
weeks because it all started with a
spring statement with the fact that he
on the one hand people on the right of
the tory party very upset that he will
not reduce taxes and on the left you're
very upset that he's actually not
targeting more support to the very
poorest in society look he's stuck
between a rock and a hard place even
before uh the last few days
in terms of satisfying people he knows
he's got 400 billion of borrowing on the
back of covert and when he was handing
out um all that cash over the last
couple of years he was the greatest
thing since
cyrus the great in the sixth century bc
he's now suddenly become uh vilified a
vilified figure and look i think rishi
sunak is one of the most competent
diligent hard-working intelligent people
in the government he's also a grown-up
but i do think there are questions about
the judgment and the politics you've got
to remember rishi sunak
has had a meteoric rise he was only
elected in 2015 and only two and a half
years ago was a junior minister in the
department of local government he's
actually had a stratospheric rise the
problem with that is he's certainly very
clever and very capable the problem with
it is you learn on the job and politics
is a very tough business as anna will
tell you and the prime minister has his
own fair share of scrapes but he's got
the height of a rhinoceros the question
for richie sunak is this is a test for
him can he tough it out
or will he quit
uh and just very quickly anna what wishy
sonic has said uh previously that he
believes he's being briefed against from
within number ten
of course there's a surprise
i mean you get you i don't think labour
are going to be claiming if if it is a
scalp to be claimed um they won't be
claiming it because they're not the
people who've got this information and
leaked it so then you have to say well
where's it come from and we all know
that boris johnson is desperate to cling
on to paris he is in real trouble
however much um he's been able to avoid
it because of obviously the terrible war
in ukraine but he is still in big
trouble and so in whose interests is it
given that rishi soon as ali is quite
properly said
was an absolute rising star hugely
popular in the conservative party
popular in the country a threat
therefore to boris johnson and it's not
a big surprise if it's come from number
10 at all and of course prime minister
says no not from him but we can't
believe a word he says anna and ali
thank you very much for the moment we
are going to take a break there coming
up more of the press review including
this story on the telegraph front page
russia calls up retired soldiers after
mounting losses please stay with us for
more
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me the former government
minister anna subri and the columnist
for the article ali mirage there you
both i thought you were going to
abandon me for a moment popped in at
just the right moment let's take a look
at the telegraph front page and this is
a story about russia calling up retired
soldiers this is after their reported
mounting losses um casualties from the
the war and we ourselves spoke to dmitry
peskov putin's spokesperson last week
and for the first time in that exclusive
interview actually admitted to huge
russian losses but now we read that they
are calling up retired soldiers ali
yes julian i think it's clear that
president putin
miscalculated and miscalculated badly
not only
has uh his military suffered huge losses
but also he has made his country a
pariah
facing very very harsh economic
sanctions and a complete and utter
change
in europe's energy security strategy um
moving away from uh dependence on
russian energy which has been an
achilles heel of european
makers for far too long in fact france
tim emmons has said now that the eu is
going to try and reduce its uh imports
of russian gas by two-thirds by the end
of the year you had boris johnson and
kiev yesterday walking around zalensky's
obviously very
happy with the support that um johnson
has given him another 100 million uh in
weaponry to be committed and they are
fighting back very hard and have pushed
the russians back um to a second
strategy now where they're going to be
focusing more on trying to retain what
they've got in donbass
but now the ukrainians are talking about
even pushing further
and getting rid of the russians
completely from their territory now that
may happen i still think it's quite
unlikely it may be a case of 1989 in
afghanistan where the the russians left
with their tail between their legs but i
think still think it's highly unlikely i
think what is more likely and this is
not being talked about enough is that
zelensky is going to have to sit down
with putin however unpalatable that is
and negotiate a piece and the question
is
how many more people have to die before
that happens but for now at least the
ukrainians seem to have their tails up
and are willing to press on
and it just says very quickly you've got
about 30 seconds um can you see
diplomacy coming through at this stage
i honestly genuinely don't know because
you see it's such high stakes for putin
isn't it and it's difficult to see him
backing off
zelensky an outstanding leader his
people and his troops extremely
courageous but it's absolutely
imperative upon the rest of the uh of
the almost the alliance behind him to
make sure he has the equipment
immediately that he needs i'm still
quite hawkish on the whole thing i have
to say
i still don't think that we've been
strong enough in standing up to putin
anna and ali thank you so much see you
in the next hour
you